all right
cindy hi cindy uh where'd you grow up
where you from originally
um from pacquiao san fernando valley
okay and tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents
um basically my dad died when uh before
i was born
right before i was born tragic accident
at work or something
so i never met my dad my mom raised me
and my two brothers
and it was basically okay childhood
except for the fact that
i was touched by every one of my uncles
my mom had six brothers
and um basically i know now that she
traded
you know molestation acts to me for
drugs and stuff like that
everything came out later on and um i
was even kidnapped by one of my uncles
um for about two weeks and i was
pregnant with this child
by 10 years old and um i couldn't keep
the baby or nothing like that
you were pregnant at what age ten yeah i
had just
started my period and i didn't even know
that i was pregnant
except that my mom kept tabs on like
getting me pads and stuff like that
and um she took me to the doctor and i
was pregnant i didn't even tell her what
happened
but i was in a dark alley outside my
house and i was kidnapped
by a man in a dark mask and raped
brutally raped
and right before i got out of the van i
took off the mask and it was my uncle
and basically um a couple other people
came forward
and saw it like neighbors and stuff and
they they told they told my mom they
told the detective
he didn't go to jail and i had to press
charges but my mom was really mad at me
about it
so like throughout my whole life i
didn't really want to tell her anything
i kept things from her
because she always made me feel like it
was my fault
your mom was an addict but she was an
addict but she kept the kids
yeah and she works a good job and stuff
at
csun and so she always kept a good job
so that's kind of what made me like
always do good in school like make it
look good on the outside you know what
i'm saying
but really my mom she was a really bad
addict really bad she had alcohol
problem too
i don't know if it was like from the
loss of my dad whatever
yeah when do you go on your own um
i've been on my own probably since i was
23.
um i was addicted to sex and stuff and
drugs and i was just so ashamed
to do that around my family and for you
know
other people to see me like that that i
knew so i came to a different area
so i came downtown where nobody knew me
and continued to you know sell my body
and stuff
and i've had opportunities to like move
forward and do good and stuff but
i chose it and i'm not really sure why
but i know that like i'm hungry for
attention
and um there's a borderline where like
it feels good but it's wrong
and that's attractive to me and i think
i was just always raised feeling like
it's wrong but it's right it's wrong but
it feels good
and it's like i still live with that you
know so what kind of feelings do you
get shame and guilt and all that i feel
shame and guilt that
i'm not raising my children and how many
kids do you have
three boys who raises my mom
and it's sad because i don't know what's
going on you know with them now with my
mom i mean
i never trusted my mom ever you know
but she makes it look so good you know
but um i talk to my kids like every
other week and stuff over the phone and
skype and stuff so
your mom's still using i don't know i
just i don't see how she can
i know for sure she she uses alcohol
every day
that's her thing you know but she uses
her
her having a good job and working all
day that she's entitled to drink
she's entitled to do what she wants you
know saying as long as she's taking care
of everything financially
and that's kind of like the role i've
taken too as long as i take care of
myself financially
i can do whatever i want so today you're
you're living on the street here
i'm just i'm on the street you're in a
tent here on skid row i'm on a tent in
skid row
and i have a couple tents i have a
boyfriend who's really controlling
um kind of like a pimp if you want to
call it
yeah that's how you're making money yeah
and most of it goes to him
and he doesn't like what i do but he
gets to spend all of it
and it's just like a revolving circle of
going outside getting the money doing
the drugs and going back outside
all day every day now even i mean i'm
missing work you know but i really
wanted to come and do this
[Music]
and he's got to get depressing for you
right it's so depressing
it's very hard every day and to put on a
smile
and i mean people know like if you're
going through something they don't want
to pick you up you know what i'm saying
so
i have to look as good as possible
that's why
i'm not your typical looking prostitute
you know i mean
and i don't dress up all naked or
whatever
and the people who know me they're loyal
to me you know what i mean and it's more
of a conversation
than it is anything you know what i'm
saying um they're able to see
like the real underneath part of me yeah
regular customer system i have regular
people that have been coming for five
years
every week loyally and
sometimes they don't have the money
sometimes they do and and if i see them
on the street and i need something
you know they'll stop and they'll give
me a couple bucks here and there
or furniture or anything blankets i mean
i'm willing to do anything just to get
by what is your drug today
it's crack how long you've been using
crack oh it's going on
23 years so you started early
yeah i had a 18 year old boyfriend i was
like
really young at the time and he got me
started on that
and i just been in love with it ever
since
i just i stopped i i stopped for a
little bit but
i always just craved to go back what did
crack do for you when you first
started using it it gave me like
feelings of feeling sexy
and beautiful and mellow
horny all feelings sexual feelings to me
and what does it do for you today same
thing it still works
same thing okay you're not just yeah but
more of it's more like a chemical
balance to me
for like a mood stabilizer today um i
don't get as high on it as i used to
unless it's really good you find out as
pure as it used to be
right stomped on you know but it's like
it makes me mad because i keep going to
get it
keep going to get it no matter if it's
short it's bad it's whatever
i'm going no matter what i'm going
i don't know for how long i mean what
what is
i mean what certainly you're an
intelligent woman and you you see that
that's
going to lead nowhere in your life i
know but you can't break free of it
yeah what what what do you think people
watching this
wouldn't just don't understand about
addiction um
i think um it has a lot to do for
with me in my opinion has a lot to do
with um family being there for you
or friends a good support group because
i don't have any of that
and i never have and i i guess that's
what i'm missing
did you ever feel loved as a child not
really no
no dad no dad i just been on a search
for love and trying to fill a hole that
can't be filled
and i don't know what it is i don't know
if it's god i mean i have god in my life
now
i don't feel as empty and i do have my
kids
you know that i talk to so i don't feel
as empty but i definitely feel like i'm
going nowhere
i just don't want to die out here
i like this have you been clean before
i've been clean probably the most for
like three four years
i've had a steady job but then i always
end up going back
what sets you back what makes you
relapse my relapse
i just like that urge even going to
meetings even going to like any meetings
like i feel like using during the ending
meeting like i don't know
like talking about it not talking about
it you know
is it like a constant battle just to not
use yeah even when you're clean
yeah because it like i feel good when
i'm clean i like myself better but
i can't wait to do it again it's it's
like that constant like
i know it's wrong but it feels good it's
like never ending story in my life you
know
is it wrong because it feels good i grew
up with that feeling
even in my sex life with my boyfriend i
mean i can't be with him unless we're
doing some kind of role play based on my
childhood
trauma i'm constantly asking him to
pretend he's my uncle or my daughter
or some kind of family member
and it's embarrassing to say but that's
the truth
literally i think he feels bad
yeah and working here picking up guys on
skate road that's dangerous sometimes
man
yeah what kind of what kind of stuff is
i mean i've been stabbed
um i've been kicked out of cars you know
beat up
you know i'm drugged i'm saying just
people have stolen my money made me do
do the do and then
taking my money and i've been walked
home you know with no shoes no clothes
you know after doing a whole night of
job you know and it
it's the worst feeling i'm mad at myself
mad at myself i won't go do this with
somebody i don't know this time
but when i'm desperate it's like i have
no choice
whatever comes up you know do you have
any friends
i really don't i think i can say i have
one friend
and i don't know how loyal that person
is
what do you think might help you get out
of this situation
myself just to just i don't know
i mean god and me i don't know i'd like
to say
oh if i had a really good job that came
up you know or if i moved
but i think no matter where i would go i
would search out
my drug or or end up working somehow i
don't know
do you think there's something about
this this life that just is it
is addictive is attractive yeah
not just the drug it's everything yeah
you feel like you belong everything
situation this life it's so weird
because i'm not from here but
i never felt like i belonged so much to
my life
whereas if you were living in a
beautiful house somewhere in a nice
neighborhood with a beautiful car and
family
exactly i come from money and now i'm
working for it probably
i didn't need for anything i had my own
car if you had that now you'd probably
sabotage it right
right and it's almost like um
like i'm punishing myself or something
and not even because i deserve it
because my mom always told me that i
deserved it
she always made me feel like everything
i did i egged it on i brought it on
it was called for you know i'm saying
and
some somewhere deep down i think maybe
it happened to her
maybe it's normal for her maybe it's
like a repetition thing you know
yeah it's almost like the generational
curse continues on exactly
your kids are and everybody knows it
everybody knows it
but nobody talks about it but now your
kids are
living with their grandmother yeah and i
just don't know what's going on and i
don't want to sabotage them with
dcfs so it's like until i hear otherwise
i'm just going along with it
i don't really have any control over it
anyway like
i just i just eventually want to be
somebody that my kids
can look up to or say that she was this
bad but
she made it out and i take
responsibility for
you know the way i'm living now you know
what i'm saying i know that i can do
better and i should do better
i want to do better i just i don't know
what the first
step is yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
that everybody has problems in their
life nobody's perfect
i'm saying um nobody's better than
anybody else
but we all need each other in some way
everybody needs somebody and
not to judge because i don't
we don't want to be judged i don't want
to be judged you know what i'm saying
and i think that i've learned out here
to be a better person
to humans in general and not to look
down upon other people
in a worse position than i am or better
because i've been in both sides you know
what i'm saying
i just want to be happy i just want to
love people and i think like
how they say love conquers all i think
you know if we all just got along better
you know and helped each other more
that we all be okay you know and i found
a piece of god and
i i i want more it might be my way out
all right cindy well thank you so much
for talking with me thank you good luck
with
with your life from here thank you very
much thank you thanks
you